legit tastes like blueberry if you
marinated blueberries in I don't know
semen for a week maybe so today we're
trying bizarre sodas like Pizza soda Oh
No
is there like a vomit flavored soda cuz
I will spit that at you I've had a sip
of bacon flavored soda how it was
horrible okay this smells like medicine
right now it's really good
well I wouldn't know that I can't taste
anything Oh butter I think it's like
bread what jelly
I just wish there's a crunch in it bread
in the wall this is my lace you know I
smell something i-team is what it's fine
for a second and then it's the worst
thing in the world
ah that's buttered popcorn for sure oh
corn sweet Oh
you keep drinking it I kind of like it
this is straight up this does not look
like my pee at all I don't know what
your you need to drink more water oh I
know what this smells like oh oh it's
awful no oh no no it tastes kind of good
you're wrong I think it sucks
I'm gonna guess blueberry pie dressing
that is not ranch
do you like ranch I did
Oh smell it that's bacon oh I'm late
that once throw for sure point that way
Oh whoo no no no no no oh well I don't
think it's big he only had a taste it
would be good you know I think it's
Sharpie cranberry it was bacon it was
bacon
I don't even smell like bacon bacon
smells good
this is the worst out I've ever tasted
in my whole life ten minutes ago we were
happy people we were happy people our
breath smells so good I would buy them
to give it to a friend that I really
didn't like I like the first three the
first three I maybe go for the first one
I need a real soda now to wash this
taste out of my mouth
[Music]